[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAY CHANDRASHEKARAN: We're
here to talk about Target's
application platform.
Just want to know
quickly, how many of you
know about Target corporation?
Yeah, this is our
team over here.
You folks from retail, how
many from the retail industry?
Good, OK.
Great.
So a little bit
about Target and then
we will kind of move forward.
So we have about 1800 plus
stores in US in all 50 states.
We have about
350,000 team members.
Our headquarters
is in Minneapolis.
We do have locations
in California,
and in Bangalore in India.
About 30 million guests
visit our stores each week.
So our e-commerce website
receives a significant amount
of traffic every month.
It's kind of like the fourth
most visited retail website
in the United States,
but our website
is just one part of
our digital strategy.
Our flagship mobile app allows
you to easily purchase products
from your mobile phone.
Convenient features like
a map with locations
of the product that
you are looking for
and wallet, which allows
you to combine discounts
such as cartwheel and then kind
of combine it with red card
discount and quickly check out.
So we also have features
like ship and drive up,
and these do provide
convenience services for you
to purchase stuff
right out of your car
or get stuff delivered
straight to your home.
Another interesting
thing that we do
is drive up, which gives you
a way to order items online
and then we kind of
notify you once your items
are ready to be picked up.
You let us know what car you're
driving, the color of your car,
you drive to the store,
we use geo fencing.
Somebody will walk
out, scan your app,
but the items in your
car, and you can move.
So that's kind of like a
great service that we provide,
but that's the
marketing side of it.
So we are here to
talk about tech.
I didn't introduce
myself, but Jim and I
are talking here today.
I'll let Jim introduce
himself, and he'll go forward.
JIM BEYERS: Sure.
My name's Jim Beyers.
I run platform services
inside of cloud
and compute inside of
infrastructure and operations
at Target.
Our team essentially
is writing the software
that's powering TAP--
Target Application
Platform-- that we're here
to talk to you about.
And Jay.
JAY CHANDRASHEKARAN:
I work with Jim.
So my team is responsible
for the compute services--
the underlaying, the VMs, and
the Kubernetes clusters that
run in our data centers, in
stores, and in Google Cloud.
The talk that we are going to
give today is a body of work
that our teams have done
over the last year or so.
So what we plan to do here
is kind of share our journey
that led us to build an
application development
platform.
So I'll share the landscape
we had prior to building
the platform at Target, the
problem we're trying to solve,
and then we will
talk a bit about some
of the principles that
formed the basis of building
this application platform.
And then we'll
share a little bit
about that inner
workings of the platform,
and we'll give you a walkthrough
of how a developer interacts
with the platform.
And we'll finish
off sharing with you
folks what's the current status
of it and our future plans,
so to speak.
So how we got here.
I think many of you who
have been in the industry
for a while can
probably relate to this.
How it goes about is
application development
teams need to build
and deploy like an app,
they reach out generally
to infrastructure teams,
they make a specific request,
the infra teams place an order,
wait for the servers to arrive,
we rack them and turn it over
to our development teams,
and kind of use it.
Simple, right?
But it's kind of complex
at the same time.
We even did service enable
the access to the computer.
But it only provided,
again, incremental benefit.
So what are the problems that we
faced just by providing access
to compute directly?
Infrastructure change fatigue.
The teams who got
their pet servers
ended up spending a
lot of time patching.
Infra teams like ours ended
up spending a lot of time
tacking abandoned servers on new
servers, doing server upgrades.
For service enabled platforms
like OpenStack, Kubernetes,
we still ended up asking
teams to do the work,
to make changes to
support the platform,
to do upgrades, migrations,
things like that.
So development team still end
up with a significant amount
of infrastructure work in
their backlog, basically.
And this has been kind
of disruptive for them.
So that's one part.
Now, there is the other part
from a developer standpoint.
So the developer faced
very disparate experiences.
They need to deploy applications
to our data centers,
to our stores, our distribution
centers, to Google Cloud.
Deployment to
OpenStack in our data
centers very different than how
do we deploy to Google Cloud
or to our edge locations
that run Kubernetes?
These are all different.
So the development team ended
up using different deployment
tools, and they
had to build them,
they had to maintain
these tool chains,
and this is work for
the development teams.
Application
development teams like
that support our distributed--
that work with our distributed
platforms like stores
sometimes end up spending even
70% of their development time
in deploying workloads to these
distributed edge locations.
Plus on top of this,
there is no standards
in terms of how teams can
implement logging, monitoring,
basic operational stuff.
Sometimes there are
too many options,
sometimes there are
too less options,
so it's kind of
hard for developers
to figure out what's the
right pattern to use.
So we started off by
removing technical debt.
So what's technical debt?
We declare it as anything.
It can be obsolete
hardware, underused
applications, anything
that prevents you
basically from building
capacity in a modern technology.
So we started working towards
removing technical debt.
So we literally like
removed physical hardware
from our data centers,
which are legacy.
We removed thousands
of equipments
from our stores,
old PDAs, servers,
and just we retired
hundreds of applications.
So just to help teams get
rid of these legacy backlogs
so that they can
focus on building new.
And how does it help?
So one, it helps
by us not having
to pay millions of dollars in
terms of vendor licensing cost.
And this also frees up
application development teams
to start building more
than applications.
And we started with that, and
we gave them direct access
to our service enabled
compute platforms,
and that doesn't help.
They will basically
end up with a whole lot
more work when the lifecycle of
these compute services come up.
And this is where
TAP comes into play,
so Jim will talk about how
we approached that problem.
JIM BEYERS: Thanks, Jay.
So Jay outlined the
history as to why we
decided we needed to build TAP.
I think you probably
all can relate
pretty closely with a lot of
things he was talking about.
So before we decided how to
do what we're going to do,
we decided to sort of the
why, if that makes sense.
And honestly, even before
we started with the why
we started with the who.
So a peer of Jay and ours, a
guy by the name of Dan Woods,
came up with this
concept of someone
that he referred to as
the midnight developer.
And the midnight
developer is someone
who is starting from nothing,
she may have never interacted
with the platform before,
maybe she started today,
and she's trying to
get something together
for her demo the next day.
If she can't build a
fully featured demo
without having to have a
meeting, or a Service Now
request, or whatever your
ticketing platform is,
we've failed as a team.
And disclaimer, don't
work at midnight.
Have a life.
So the six principles that we
came up with are as follows.
So the first one's self
service like I mentioned,
it's zero [INAUDIBLE]
up and running.
Empower the teams to get
their project off the ground
without needing to interface
with any of the platform teams.
No meetings, basically.
Common patterns of usability.
So teams will interact
with the platform offerings
in a common way.
So when Jay was talking
about disparate experiences,
if you have two write Chef
scripts to deploy things
to stores and you are using
Spinnaker deployed to GCP,
that's--
we're not having a
common experience.
Discoverability, teams should
be able to quickly and easily
ascertain what the capabilities
are that are available to them
on the platform.
So essentially similar
to the no meetings,
it should be like
not no docs, but it
should be fairly intuitive
to open up the page,
look at what you need to
do, I need a load balancer,
click a button.
Not read for 30 minutes or try
and find some tribal knowledge.
No searching wiki pages.
Availability, it's got
to be up all the time.
We're not going have maintenance
windows, and dev is prod.
Everything's an application.
TAP uses TAP, we
bootstrap TAP with itself.
That's a big broad conversation.
If you'd like to
hear more about it,
I'd have to talk to
you about it after.
And then strong
opinions loosely held.
So that means that the
decisions that we made today
for the underlying
implementations
of the componentry
of the platform
may not be the appropriate
decisions for the underlying
componentry of the
platform tomorrow.
So we need to build the
platform in such a way
that we can swap things in
and out interchangeably,
and we've done that quite
a bit in the last year.
So what do we build?
We built TAP, we
already know that.
It's the Target
Application Platform.
And TAP is this
consistent experience
like we outlined
in the principles.
What tap is not is
GitHub Enterprise.
It is not Artifact Read,
it is not Spinnaker,
it is not Kubernetes,
it is not OpenStack,
it's none of these things.
It's essentially the
overlying platform
that abstracts you away
from these independent tools
so that you've got a consistent
experience across all of them.
It's like the glue code
that we wrote to do this.
And we did this by
starting by saying,
like, we're going
to look at what's
the fundamental underlying
runtime components that we
need to have, and obviously
one of those is compute.
So Kubernetes is a fantastic
container scheduler.
It's also a great platform,
but it's a fantastic container
scheduler.
So we started with the
idea of let's figure
out how we can
leverage the scheduling
aspects of Kubernetes,
but open up
so that we can use other pieces
of the runtime components
other than Kubernetes.
So in other words,
what I'm saying is
we're not just dumping
everything into Kubernetes.
So what we did was
we wrote shim layers
in front of each
deployment of Kubernetes
so that we're deploying
through the shim.
So what that means
specifically is
we decided to use the
Kubernetes deployment
spec for every
deployment when we
deploy to a compute provider.
And what that allows us to do
is to have multiple instances
of Kubernetes that could be
potentially different versions,
they can be running on
obviously different compute,
and ultimately that's all
abstracted away from the users.
We recently ran into the
Kubernetes 1.6 vulnerability
I'm sure everybody is used to.
There were break-in changes
in the contract between 1.6
and whatever we went to, 1.14,
that was work for people.
And that goes back to what Jay
was saying before about how
we don't want them
to have to worry
about these kinds of things.
The other really cool thing
that this allows us to do
is to present other
compute providers
with the same deployment spec.
So you write your
app once, and you
can deploy it to Kubernetes,
you can deploy it--
we started with OpenStack
for our VM provider which
solved a different problem.
Whereas before we ran into some
issues with large installations
of compute services
providers like OpenStack
with doing things like
infrastructure upgrades,
now we can do our favorite
tagline, more of them
smaller so that if
we want to take out
some compute provider for
maintenance or something
like that, all we have to
do is have teams redeploy.
We can take things offline,
nobody even needs to know,
which is pretty sweet.
And so we can do the same thing
with other compute providers,
rinse repeat.
How do we deploy to
those compute providers?
We wrote what we call this
platform intelligent engine,
or PIE, that implements the
Kubernetes deployment spec also
and then makes an intelligent
placement decision to one
of those compute providers.
Now to be honest, the
actual intelligence
of the platform
intelligence engine
right now is not
particularly intelligent.
We taken some of
the different specs,
like we have these
other concepts I'll
touch on a little
bit like pool type,
or if you're a
compliant workload,
or if you want to be a VM
or a container or runtime,
and then we make a decision.
And some of the ways that
we do that right now is just
by waiting or giving preference
to specific what we call pie
slices-- that's a
compute provider--
to say, hey, deploy here.
A really crazy and great story
is Jay's team wrote something
that we call SGDM.
It stands for Server
Group Deployment Manager,
and all it does is
it's a VM runtime.
Dead simple, runs VMs
really, really well.
And we moved almost all of
our non-compliant workloads
that we're running on
OpenStack over to SGDM,
and none of our users even
knew, which is pretty rad.
So that's that.
So that covers the
compute provider aspects.
The other areas
obviously of the platform
is this is not just
running CPU cycles.
We've got things like config,
and secrets, load balancing,
log metrics, and potentially
things like an API layer or API
proxy.
Today, I should say we started
with console for config.
We've taken out
pieces of console
over the course of our
journey and replaced them
with some homegrown
pieces, et cetera.
And our users didn't
know, which was great.
We used Vault for secrets, we're
using Fabio for load balancing.
When you deploy for
instance, basically it
auto registers with
the load balancer,
which is pretty sweet.
And this goes back to
that principle of the fact
that we might make decisions
today that tomorrow we
might want to change.
So I'm going to
do a walkthrough,
but I want to cover
some basic core concepts
and terminology that's going to
be somewhat probably important.
I'll try and go
over this quickly,
because maybe it's going to
be rudimentary for people.
So an application is
essentially a project.
You start your application
inside of the UI
or through the API.
Everything in TAP
is API first, so you
don't have to interact with
the API if you don't want to.
You can use a CLI that we
also have, it's pretty great.
Application is essentially
the container for your code.
Inside of an application,
there's a concept of a cluster.
An application can
have many clusters.
Clusters belong
to an environment.
We only have two,
there's dev and prod.
Clusters are the logical
organization of infrastructure.
You can have one or many
deployments, like I said.
So you deploy to a cluster.
Instances and server groups.
So you're docker container,
or your VM is an instance.
You can have one to many of
them inside of a server group.
That's your basically
unit of deployment.
One of the things that
we do require inside
of every application
is that every instance
has an instance health check.
So you can run any
docker container
you want on the platform, but
it has to have a health check.
And the reason that
we implemented that
is so that if your application
is up and healthy as determined
by you, then it will
register with a load balancer
and start taking traffic.
Currently we only
take HDTV traffic,
but that's in flight
very quick for us
to be able to do TCPL also.
And then there's this
concept of stacks.
So as I said
before, applications
are globally namespaced.
Stacks are also
globally namespaced such
that you can have a--
so Red Sky's an
application at Target.
You can have a Red Sky UAT, you
can have a Red Sky performance,
you can have a Red
Sky red sky if you
want to all in production.
And so that allows you to
wire different deployments
of your application together so
that you don't get interference
if that's what you want, say,
specifically for performance.
So that covers the sort
of high level concepts.
I just wanted to
say because you're
in to see some of
those in the UIs.
We weren't brave enough
to actually do a demo,
but I have video shots, video
screenshots of the app here.
And I'd be happy to show
anybody this later if they're
interested, and
I can get on VPN.
All, right bear with me because
taking video screenshots
of stuff is a little bit wonky.
So-- shoot, see I
already went too fast.
So this shows here that
basically my screen
as a user of TAP.
Shows all the teams that
I'm on inside of TAP
because you might want
to be able to allow
other people to deploy your
application besides just
yourself.
Seems reasonable, right?
I'm going to walk you through
what we call quick start.
I'm going to create
an app on TAP.
So I'm going to click that
button, I'm going to say,
I want to start a
new project, or I
could start with existing code.
If you ever used a platform
as a service, some of this
should look familiar to you.
But obviously, some of
it's Target specific.
So I'm going to choose
my application name.
It's my next demo, I think.
Yep.
And I'm just going to make sure
that it's available if it is.
Now this is mine.
I'll come back to this, but
essentially when it gets
deployed it's
mynextdemo.dev.target.com.
Or if I'm in prod it's
mynextdemo.prod.target.com.
Hit that, you go directly
to the app or the stack
if you're using stacks.
Blossom ID is essentially
just like a configuration ID.
It's like a metadata
service at Target
that allows us to do
things like charge backs--
or not charge backs,
sorry-- show back,
so that we can show how much
specific apps are costing,
et cetera, or to
be able to tie back
to a particular
line of business.
And then the team,
like I talked about
before, if I want to give
access to other people
to manage my application
inside of TAP
I can add them to my team.
And I'm going to add
my contacting email
in my description,
and then I'm going
to say, hey, what GitHub
organization do I want?
And I'm going to choose me,
and I'm going to say, go.
And then I'm going to decide--
here's the four things
that we support so far.
So Praxis is an internal target
UI react set of components.
It's more or less how most front
end stuff is written in Target.
So I can click Praxis app,
I can do a Spring Boot app,
I can do a Ratpack app
or a Ratpack with Groovy.
But 85% of the target apps
are Spring Boot, we think,
so I'm just going to do that.
Also, it's the one
I know how to do.
And then I get to decide
between a container
and a virtual machine.
So like we said before,
it's not specific
to the actual compute
provider because we
want to have the capability
of being able to decide what's
the best thing for today.
So maybe today it's
OpenStack-- but it's not--
now it's SGDM.
So we decided to
do virtual machine
so that we could make
those decisions as we're
the ones that are supporting
the infrastructure.
And the same thing we believe is
true for containers-- probably
Kubernetes, though.
So I chose container,
and it's just
telling me what it's
going to do now,
which is going to scaffold
out some code in GitHub,
it's going to create
my Drone config,
and it's going to run
my build in Drone.
So drones are a CI tool if you
guys aren't familiar with it,
and then it's going to create
my cluster and deploy my code.
So I forgot that I had
to be signed into Drone
when I made this.
So I signed into Drone
and then it did it.
So you can see here that
it actually had already
been working but I wasn't signed
in, and so it built my code.
So like I said, this
is a little bit wonky.
Give me a second.
There we go, sorry.
So after that, this
is just a short screen
that shows essentially
that we met
the scaffolded code in GitHub.
It ran my Drone job, and
it created the cluster.
And then after that, it
actually created the cluster
but I wanted to show
what it's like for you
to create your own.
So this concept is
the concept of stacks.
So this goes back
into like if I wanted
to have different environments
inside of my environment
because I wanted to test
out different lines of code,
here's my next demo dash dev.
It's available.
I'm going to click
Continue, and then these
are just some of
the config items
that people can select from.
So today we only allow to
deploy to the data center.
We started some work on
being able to deploy it
to public cloud or to GCP.
And then also obviously
as Jay mentioned,
our goal is to be able
to deploy workloads also
to stores and to
distribution centers.
So pool type is
something that we also
allow for you to be
able to sort of define
if you've got constraints
with respect to your runtime.
So if you are a Sox
application, you
would choose that you
wanted the Sox pool type.
We have some special
sort of stuff
that we reserve only to
certain users at Target.
So like there's a group
that's doing work on GPU.
We created a PIE slice that was
able to deploy to some GPUs,
and they're able to see that
in here, which is pretty slick.
And then there's the proprietor
type like I chose earlier,
there is a container
in the M runtime.
And then the region
at the end is
we've got TTC and TTE are
the two target data centers,
and then there's also
an option to choose HA.
I'll come back to that
because this is essentially
just like my app is
running on port 8080, which
is the one that Load
Balancer is going to hit.
And then I got some choices that
look very similar to Kubernetes
with respect to
how many millicores
and how much memory I want.
This is the health
check I talked about.
So you can implement
your health check however
you want, but you
have to have one
so that we know that your app
is up and available because we
don't want the load
balancer to route traffic
to garbage instances
that are not working.
This is just basically
the config for that.
This is the deployment strategy.
Today we only support two,
red-black, or blue-green
depending on if you are
more akin to Netflix,
and then Highlander.
So deploy my instance group,
wait for it to be healthy,
and then I'll start
running traffic to it
or deploy it and then destroy
the other one right away.
Which I'm embarrassed
to say it took me
a long time to realize why
it was called Highlander.
There can be only one.
So a server group
capacity is just how many
instances do I want to deploy?
You can say one.
I don't think we have a limit.
I know for sure that there's
some people that have 80.
Actually, it may
be more than that.
Choose the size of the number
of instances that you want
and then deploy.
We do have plans in the
future to be able to do things
with the platform
intelligence engine to say,
like, hey, someone today
might say, hey man,
I'm going to get a million TPS.
Well, that's
generally never true.
And so they might
weigh over provision,
and we could have
the potential--
since every app
that's deployed is
using the runtime connector
is automatically instrumented
with logs of metrics.
So we know the
health of everything
as long as it's running with
a health check and point
and it's using the
runtime connector.
So we would be able to do
what I'm talking about,
which is if it's taking two
TPS and running at 0.01%
CPU utilization, we probably
would scale them down
in the future.
And then like I said before,
everything is API first.
So you'll see here
that that's essentially
the JSON of what the
API will look like.
Next, details.
So now that I've deployed my
cluster, it's up and running.
I'm just going to go and
check and say, hey, here's
my pipeline.
We're using pieces of
Spinnaker under the covers
to run deployments for TAP.
There's quite a bit
of custom pieces
that we've taken out
and rewritten ourselves
because they were more akin
to our use case, I'll say.
So essentially, that's
your Spinnaker pipeline--
create the server group,
disable the old one,
and create the new one.
Here's the UI for
config and secrets.
So for console for config
and alt for secrets,
you can enter your
stuff in right here,
and it will get injected
in your application
provided you've written
your code correctly.
And this is basically
going back and being
able to edit those constraints
I showed you earlier if you
want to do your deployment.
It's not an uncommon thing
for us to find customers
that deploy to the
container runtime
and find out that they're
actually very compute-intensive
workloads that they decide
that it's better for them
to run on VMs.
That's actually quite common.
And oh yeah, so inside
my group of server groups
there would be if I had
more than one instance, all
the individual instance.
I can go directly
to my instance logs,
directly to my health
check in points.
So I clicked on
that, that takes me
to the logs specific
for that runtime--
sorry, for that container.
There is health checks
specifically for that instance.
And so this is pretty slick.
And the reason I said
before about the HA,
I was happy to have
caught one earlier.
But basically,
what we see here is
a sort of production view of the
Platform Intelligence Engine.
So on the bottom are a list
of all of the PIE slices,
which if you remember
is the facade that sits
in front of a compute provider.
So you can kind of infer
what most of them are.
The first one is
K8's provider that's
running inside of
our TTS data center,
and we've got 1,300
instances in there.
You can see that overall,
of all of TAP we've got
a little over 20,000 running.
And I think it comes
right at 20 seconds.
You can actually see in
the PIE slice activity
the little spiral dealeo actual
deployments that are going on,
which is kind of cool.
And right at 20 seconds,
you'll see that two happen,
and it's an HA deploy.
One, two, TTC and the
other one did TTCE.
If you scroll down, then you'll
see some of those constraints
like we talked about.
Just about everything
in here, I think,
is-- well no, that's not true.
Most everything is obviously
gen pop, hence Gen population,
but you've got the Sox pool
type running on OpenStack.
You've got Gen Pop
running on a VM,
this is that SGDM I
was talking about,
and there's a bunch of different
PIE slices in here, including I
think the--
I can't find it.
I don't remember.
I know the GPU one is in here.
There's like four GPUs,
it's not that cool.
So that is PIE, and
Jay's going to talk now
a little bit about the status
of TAP and where we're at today.
JAY CHANDRASHEKARAN:
Thanks, Jim.
Can we switch over
to the slides?
JIM BEYERS: Oh, just--
yeah, that's fine.
JAY CHANDRASHEKARAN:
So current status.
This was launched last year,
specifically like April 1st.
It's not a talk as such.
So we're exactly one year
into building the platform
and running it.
And you can see
the adoption curve,
it's just kind of rocketed up.
And this is real.
It's running production
workloads in Target,
supporting our business.
This chart is a few weeks
old, and the current one,
it's still growth is
like the same pace.
We now have about 5,400
applications running.
We have about 20,000 instances
for deployments per minute.
That's happening.
So we think about
it, the friction
that we are removing from
our development teams,
they are doing like about
5,700 deployments per day.
And just by clicking
buttons, this
is like the work they
don't have to do.
So that's actual
advantage for us.
So future plans.
So our vision is
that TAP will be
one stop shop for
all compute and data
needs for our developers.
So we will accomplish
this by abstracting
the compute and the
data provider layers
away from the developers
as Jim demoed it.
So they no longer have to
worry about which version
of Kubernetes they
are running on,
whether they are
running on Google Cloud
or in our data centers.
Jim also demoed and
talked about PIE earlier.
This component of the TAP will
become intelligent over time.
And with that
intelligence we will
be able to make automatic
workload placements using TAP,
basically determining
which is the best
location to run the workload.
We also have a greater
ability to improve efficiency
of our compute platforms.
We can actually understand
applications of source usage,
and even if they are
allocated a higher resource
than what they actually
need the platform
can actually dial it down.
We also have, of course, in
our custom compute platform
we have much better
ability to overprovision--
we actually see about 70% to 80%
of physical compute utilization
in our custom compute platform,
which is kind of great.
So our plans.
Jim kind of touched on it too.
Currently our
focus is on getting
things running in data center.
We are going to switch over
to get this thing working
in Google Cloud and to our
edge locations and stores
and distribution centers.
We already have
Kubernetes clusters
running in our stores
and distribution centers.
The plan is to
have this platform
that we build called
unimetrics, integrate that
with TAP so that developers
interact with TAP.
And that's the way they will
deploy workloads in Target
they're not going to have any
of those disparate experiences.
As I mentioned
earlier, we can move
workloads that around based on
attributes like availability,
response time.
With TAP, we should be able to
bus workload into Google Cloud
if we need to, or we can
automatically move workloads
to our edge if we need a better
response time or availability.
So basically, we see
TAP as the one stop shop
for our developers to
interact with infrastructure.
So we are excited
about our journey,
and we believe TAP gives
our developers the ability
to focus on
delivering new feature
functions for our guests
and build productivity
tools for our team members.
And thanks to TAP, I believe
our application developers
will be able to do this at
a much faster rate than any
of our competitors
in our industry.
Thanks.
JIM BEYERS: Thanks, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]